I know what my father was what he did I
know the Mad King earned his name
kill every Targaryen I get my hands on
every one who was
is an enemy
so is it bring these haters what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another a Song of Ice and Fire video
today I want to read one of the most
iconic chapters from this amazing story
I know a lot of my subscribers have
never read the books so I wanted to read
some of the best chapters to you that
way you could see how different they
were from the show
I have also wanted to read some of the
best parts from the book so that the
show did not add so you could get a good
feel for how great the source material
actually is if you have read the books
then you probably won't be interested in
this but I wanted to see if people would
like these kind of videos if you do like
this and then perhaps that could read a
different chapter once a week or even
once a month I figured the best way to
start off this series would be to read
one of the greatest chapters first which
is the red wedding just to show you how
powerful this chapter actually is let me
read a few words from george RR martin
himself George said I knew the red
wedding was coming and I've been
planning it all along but when I came to
that chapter which occurs 2/3 of the way
through Storm of Swords I found I
couldn't write that chapter I skipped
over that chapter and wrote the hundreds
of pages that followed the entire book
was done except for the scene with the
red wedding and even all the aftermath
of the red wedding it was just so hard
to write that scene because I'd been
inhabiting Catelyn for so long and of
course I have a lot of affection for
Robb - although he was never a viewpoint
character and even for some of the minor
characters yeah they're minor characters
but you develop a relationship to them -
and I knew they were all going to die it
was some of the hardest writing I've
ever done but it's also one of the most
powerful scenes I've ever done so with
that being said let's begin the red
wedding takes place during one of
Caitlyn's POV chapters in the third book
a Storm of Swords the drums were
pounding pounding pounding and her head
with them pipes wailed and flutes
thrilled from the musicians gallery at
the foot of the hall fiddle screeched
horns blew the skins curled a lively
tune but the drumming drove them all the
sounds echoed off the rafters while the
guests ate drank in Chou
one another below Walder Frey must be
deaf as a stone to call this music
Catelyn sipped the cup of wine and
watched Jingle Bell prance to the sounds
of Alice Ann at least she thought it was
meant to be Alice Ann with these players
it might as easily have been to bear in
the maiden fair outside the rain still
fell but within the twins the air was
thick and hot a fire roared and the
hearth and rows of torches burned
smokily from iron sconces on the walls
yet most of the heat came off the bodies
of the wedding guests jammed in so thick
along the benches that every man who
tried to lift his cup poked his neighbor
in the ribs even on the day as they were
closer than Caitlin would have liked she
had been placed between sir Ryman Frey
and Roose Bolton and had gotten a good
nose full of both sir Ryman drank as if
Westeros was about to run short of wine
and sweated it all out under his arms he
had bathed in lemon water she judged but
no lemon could mask so much sour sweat
Roose Bolton had a sweeter smell to him
yet no more pleasant he sipped hippocras
in preference to wine or Mead an eighth
but little Catelyn could not fault him
for his lack of appetite the wedding
feast began with a thin leek soup
followed by a salad of green beans
onions and beets
River Pike poached an almond milk mounds
of mashed turnips that were cold before
they reached to the table jellied calves
brains and delete of stringy beef it was
poor fare to set before a king and the
calves brains turned Catlin stomach yet
Rob aided uncomplaining and her brother
was too caught up with his bride to pay
much attention you would never guess ed
meer complained of Roslin all the way
from Riverrun - the twins husband and
wife ate from a single plate drank from
a single cup in exchange - chest kisses
between sips most of the dishes admir
waved away she cannot blame him for that
she remembered little of the food served
at her own wedding feast did I even
taste it or spend the whole time gazing
at Ned's face wondering who he was
poor Roslin's smile had a fixed quality
to it as if someone had sewn it on
her face well she is a maid wedded but
the beddings yet to come
no doubt she's as terrified as I was rob
was seated between Alex Frey and
farewell de two of the more nubile Frey
maidens at the wedding feast I hope you
will not refuse to dance with my
daughters
Walder Frey had said it would please an
old man's heart his heart should be well
pleased then rob had done his duty like
a king he had danced with each of the
girls with that Muir's bride and the
eighth lady Frey with the widow Amy and
Roose Bolton's wife fat Waldo with the
pimply twin Serra and sarra even with
Cherie
Lord Walters youngest who must have been
all of six Catelyn wondered whether the
lord of the crossing would be satisfied
or if he would find cause for a
complaint in all the other daughters and
granddaughters who had not had a turn
with the king your sister's dance very
well she said to Sir Ryman Frey trying
to be pleasant there aren't some cousins
sir rhyming drank a swallow of wine the
sweat trickling down his cheek into his
beard a sour man and in his cups Catelyn
thought the late Lord Frey might be
niggardly when it came to feeding his
guests but he did not stint on the drink
the Ale wine in Mead were flowing as
fast as the river outside the great John
was already roaring drunk Lord Walters
son Marit was matching him cup for Cup
but Sir Whelan Frey had passed out
trying to keep up with the two of them
Catelyn would sooner Lord umber had seen
fit to stay sober but telling the great
John not the drink was like telling him
not to breathe for a few hours
small jaw number and Robin Flint sent me
a Rob to the other side of fair Walda
and Alex respectively neither of them
was drinking along with Patrick molester
and Dacey Mormont they were her son's
guards this evening a wedding feast was
not a battle but there were always
dangers when men were in their cups in a
king should never be unguarded Catelyn
was glad of that and even more glad of
the sword belts hanging on pegs along
the walls no man needs a longsword to
deal with jelly calves brains everyone
thought my lord would choose fair Walda
lady Walda bolton told
sir Wendell shouting to be heard above
the music fat Waldo was a round pink
butterball of a girl with watery blue
eyes limp yellow hair and a huge bosom
yet her voice was a fluttering squeak it
was hard to picture her in the dreadfort
in her pink lace in cape aver my lord
grandfather offered ruses bride's weight
in Silver as a dowry though so my lord
of Bolton picked me the girl's Chin's
jiggled when she laughed I weigh six
stone more than fair Walda but that was
the first time I was glad of it I'm lady
Bolton now and my cousin's still a maid
and she'll be 19 soon poor thing the
lord of the dreadfort paid the chatter
no mind Catelyn Saul sometimes he tasted
a bite of this a spoon of that tearing
bread from the loaf was short strong
fingers but the meal could not distract
him Bolton had made a toast to Lord
Walters grandsons when the wedding feast
began pointedly mentioning that Walter
and Walter were in the care of his
bastard son from the way the old man had
squinted at him his mouth sucking at the
air Catlin knew he had heard the
unspoken threat was there ever a wedding
less joyful she wondered until she
remembered her poor Sansa and her
marriage to the IMP mother take mercy on
her she has a gentle soul the heat in
smoke and noise were making her sick the
musicians in the gallery might be
numerous and loud but they were not as
specially gifted Catelyn took another
swallow of wine and allowed a page to
refill her cup a few more hours and the
worst will be over by this hour tomorrow
Rob would be off to another battle this
time with the Iron Men at moat Cailin
strange how that prospect seemed almost
a relief he will win his battle he wins
all his battles in the Ironborn or
without it King besides Ned taught him
well the drums were pounding jingle bell
hopped past her once again but the music
was so loud she could scarcely hear his
bells above the den came a sudden
snarling as two dogs fell upon each
other over a scrap of meat they rolled
across the floor snapping and biting as
a howl of mirth went up someone doused
them with
the flagon of ale and they broke apart
one limp toward the dais Lord Walters
toothless mouth opened in a bark of
laughter as the dripping wet dog shook
ale and hair all over three of his
grandsons
the sight of the dogs made Catelyn wish
once more for gray win but Rob's dire
wolf was nowhere to be seen
Lord Walder had refused to allow him in
the hall your wild beast has a taste for
human flesh
I hear the old man had said rips out
throats yes I'll have no such creature
at my Roslin's feast amongst women and
little ones all my sweet innocence gray
when is no danger to them my lord
Robb protested not so long as I am there
you were there at my gates were you not
when the wolf attacked the grandson I
sent to greet you I heard all about that
don't think I didn't know harm was done
no harm the king says no harm Peter fell
from his horse fell I lost a wife the
same way
falling his mouth worked in and out or
was she just some strumpet bastard
Walter's mother yes now I recall she
fell off her horse and cracked her head
what would your grace do if Peter had
broken his neck
give me another apology in place of my
grandson no no no it might be your king
I won't say you're not the king in the
north
huh but under my roof my role have your
wolf or have your wedding sir you'll not
have both Catelyn could tell that her
son was furious but he yielded with as
much courtesy as he could summon if it
pleases Lord Walder to serve me stewed
crow smothered in maggots he told her
I'll weed it and ask for a second Bowl
in so he had the great John had drunk
another of Lord Walters brood under the
table Peter pimple this time the lad has
a third his capacity what did he expect
Lord umber wiped his mouth stood and
began to sing a bear there was a bear a
bear all black and brown and covered
with hair his voice was not all bad
though somewhat thick from drink
unfortunately the Fiddler's and drummers
and flutists up above were playing
flowers of spring which suited the words
of the Baron the maiden fair as well as
snails
might suit a bowl of porridge even pour
jinglebell covered his ears at the
cacophony Roose Bolton murmured some
words too soft to hear and went off in
search of a privy the cramped hall was
in a constant uproar of guests and
servants coming and going a second feast
for Knights and Lords of somewhat lesser
rank was roaring along and the other
castle she knew Lord Walter had exiled
his baseborn children and their
offspring to that side of the river so
that Rob's Northman had taken to
referring to it as the bastard feast
some guests were having no doubt
stealing off to see if the bastards were
having a better time than they were some
might even be venturing as far as the
camps the phrase had provided wagons of
wine ill and Mead so the common soldiers
could drink to the wedding of Riverrun
and the twins Robb said down in Bolton's
vacant place a few more hours and this
farce is done mother he said in a low
voice as the great John saying of the
made with honey in her hair black waters
been mild as a lamb for once an uncle
Edmure seems well content in his bride
he leaned across her sir Ryman Frey
blinked and said sir yes I'd hoped to
ask Oliver to Squire for me when we head
north said Robb but I do not see him
here
would he be at the other feast Oliver
sir Ryman shook his head no not Oliver
gone gone from the castles duty I see
Rob's tone suggested otherwise when Sir
Ryman offered nothing more the King got
to his feet again would you care for a
dance mother thank you but no a dance
was the last thing she needed the way
her head was throbbing no doubt one of
Lord Walters daughters would be pleased
to partner you oh no doubt his smile was
resigned the musicians were playing iron
Lance's by then while the great John
sang the lusty lad someone should
acquaint them with each other it might
improve the harmony Catelyn turned back
to sir Ryman I had heard that one of
your cousin's was a singer a Lysander
Simon's son Alex is his sister he raised
a cup toward where she danced with Robin
Flint well a Lysander be playing for us
tonight
sir Ryman squinted at her
not him he's away he wiped sweat from
his brow and lurched to his feet pardons
my lady Catelyn watched him stagger
toward the door admir was kissing Roslyn
and squeezing her hand elsewhere in the
hall
Sir Mark Piper and Sir Dan well fray
played a drinking game Lane Lothar said
something amusing to Sir hosteen one of
the younger phrase juggled three daggers
for a group of giggly girls and jingle
bells set on the floor sucking wine off
his fingers the servers were bringing
out huge silver plates piled high with
cuts of juicy pink lamb the most
appetizing dish they'd seen all evening
and Rob was leading desi Mormont in a
dance when she wore a dress lady majors
eldest daughter was quite pretty tall
and willowy with a shy smile that made
her long face light up it was pleasant
to see that she could be as graceful on
the dance floor as in the training yard
Catelyn wondered if Lady Mage had
reached the neck as yet she had taken
her other daughters with her but as one
of Rob's battle companions desi had
chosen to remain by his side he has
Ned's gift for inspiring loyalty
Oliver Frey had been downed voted to her
son as well hadn't Rob said that Oliver
wanted to remain with him even after
he'd married Jane seated betwixt his
black oak towers the Lord of the Cross
and clapped his spotted hands together
the noise they made was so faint that
even those on the dais scarce heard it
but Sir a niece and sir hosteen saw and
began to pound their cups on the table
lame Lothar joined them then Mark Piper
and Sir Dan well and Sir Raymond half
the guests were soon pounding finally
even the mob of musicians in the gallery
took note the piping drumming and
fiddling trailed off into quiet your
grace Lord Walter called out to rob the
Septon has prayed his prayers some words
have been said and Lord Edmure apt my
sweetling in a fish cloak but they are
not yet man and wife a sword needs a
sheath hay and a wedding needs a bedding
what does my sire say is it meat that we
should bed them a score or more of water
phrase sons and grandsons began to bang
their cups again shouting to bed to bed
to bed with them
Roslin had gone white
Catelyn wondered whether it was the
prospect of losing her Maidenhead that
frightened the girl or the bedding
itself was so many siblings she was not
like to be a stranger to the custom but
it was different when you were the one
being betted on catlins own wedding
night Jori castle had torn her gown in
haste to get her out of it in drunken
desmond Grell kept apologizing for every
body joke only to make another when lord
dustin had beheld her naked he told Ned
that her breasts were enough to make him
wish he'd never been weaned poor man she
thought he had ridden south with Ned
never to return Catelyn wondered how
many of the men here tonight would be
dead before the year was done too many I
fear Robb raised a hand if you think the
time is me Lord Walder by all means let
us bed them a roar of approval greeted
his pronouncement up in the gallery the
musicians took up their pipes and horns
and fiddles again and began to play the
Queen took off her sandal the king took
off his crown Jingle Bell hop from foot
to foot his own crown ringing I hear
Tolly men have trout between their legs
instead of [ __ ]
Alix Frey called out boldly to wait Sir
Mark Piper threw back
I hear that Frey women have two gates in
place of one an Alex said a but both are
closed and barred to little things like
you a gust of laughter followed until
Patrick molester climbed up onto a table
to propose a toast to ed Mears one I
fish and a mighty Pike it is he
proclaimed nay I'll wager it's a minnow
fat Walter Bolton shouted out from
Catelyn side then the general cry of bed
them bed them went up again the guests
swarmed the dais the drunken in the
forefront as ever the men and boys
surrounded Roslin and lifted her into
the air while the maids and mothers in
the hall pulled ed near to his feet and
began tugging at his clothing he was
laughing and shouting bawdy jokes back
at them though the music was too loud
for Catelyn to hear she heard the great
John tho give this little bride to me he
bellowed as he shoved through the other
men and threw Roslyn over one shoulder
look at this little thing no meat on her
at all Catelyn felt sorry for the girl
most brides tried to return the banter
or at least pretended to enjoy it but
Muslim was stiff with terror clutching
the Greatjon as if she feared he might
drop her she's crying to Catelyn
realized as she watched Sir Mark Piper
pull off one of the bride's shoes
I hope Edmure is gentle with the poor
child jolly bawdy music still poured
down from the gallery the Queen was
taking off her curdle now in the king
his tunic she knew she should join the
throng of women around her brother but
she would only ruin their fun the last
thing she felt just now was body head
near would forgive her absence she did
not doubt much jollier to be stripped
and bedded by a score of lusty laughing
phrase than by a sour stricken sister
unless your Jaime Lannister of course as
man and maid were carried from the hall
a trail of clothing behind them Catelyn
saw that Rob had also remained Walder
Frey was prickly enough to see some
insult to his daughter and dad he should
join in Roslin's bedding but is it my
place to tell him so she tensed until
she saw that others had stayed as well
Peter pimple and Sir Waylon frey slept
on their heads on the table married Frey
poured himself another cup of wine while
jingle bell wandered about stealing
bites off the plates of those who'd left
Sir Wendell Manderley was lustily
attacking a leg of lamb and of course
Lord Walder was far too feeble to leave
his seat without help he will expect
Robb to go though she could almost hear
the old man asking why his grace did not
want to see his daughter naked the drums
were pounding again pounding and
pounding and pounding desi Mormont who
seemed to be the only woman left in the
hall besides Catelyn stepped up behind
Edwin Frey and touched him lightly on
the arm as she said something in his ear
Edwin wrenched himself away from her
with unseemly violence no he said too
loudly and done what dancing for the
nonce desi paled and turned away Catelyn
got slowly to her feet what just
happened there doubt gripped her horror
where an instant before had been only
weariness it is nothing she try to tell
herself you are seeing grumpkins in the
woodpile you have become an old silly
woman sick with grief and fear but
something must have shown on her face
even sir Wendell Manderley took note is
something amiss
he asked the leg of lamb in his hands
she did not answer him instead she went
after Edwin frey the players in the
gallery had finally gotten both king and
queen down to their name des suits was
scarcely a moment's respite they begin
to play a very different sort of song no
one saying the words but Catlin knew the
rains of castamere when she heard it
Edwin was hurrying toward a door
she hurried faster driven by the music
six quick strides and she caught him in
who are you the proud Lord said that I
must bow so low she grabbed Edwin by the
arm to turn him and went cold all over
when she felt the iron rings beneath his
silken sleeve Catlin slapped him so hard
she broke his lip Oliver she thought in
Parowan a Lysander all absent in Roslin
went Edwin phrase shoved her aside the
music drowned all other sound echoing
off the walls as if the stones
themselves were playing Rob gave Edwin
an angry look and moved to block his way
in staggered suddenly as a quarrel
sprouted from his side just beneath the
shoulder if he screamed then the sound
was swallowed by the pipes and horns and
fiddles Catlin saw a second bolt pierce
his leg saw him fall up in the gallery
half the musicians had crossbows in
their hands instead of drums or lutes
she ran toward her son until something
punched in the small of the back and the
hard stone floor came up the slapper
Rob she screamed she saw small jaw
number wrestle a table off its trestles
crossbow bolts thudded into the wood one
two three as he flung it down on top of
his King
Robin Flint was reigned by phrase their
daggers rising and falling Sir Wendell
Manderley rose ponderously to his feet
holding his leg of lamb a quarrel went
into his open mouth and came out the
back of his neck Sir Wendell crashed
forward knocking the table off its
trestles and sending cups flagons
trenchers platters turnips beets and
wine bouncing spilling and sliding
across the floor Catlins back was on
fire I have to reach him the small john
bludgeoned sir raymond frey across the
face with the leg of mutton but when he
reached for his sword belt a crossbow
Boult drove him to his knees in a coat
of gold or a coat of red a lion still
has claws she saw Lucas Blackwood cut
down by Sir Hoss Teen Frey one of the
Vance's was hamstrung by black Walder as
he was wrestling with sir Harris a in
mine are long and sharp my lord as long
and sharp as yours the crossbows took
Donna luck
oh and nori in a half a dozen more young
sir been free had seized a sea Mormon by
the arm but Catelyn saw her grabbed up a
flagon of wine with her other hand and
smash it full in her face and run for
the door it flew open before she reached
it sir Ryman Frey pushed into the hall
clad in steel from helm to heel a dozen
free men at arms packed the door behind
them they were armed with heavy long
axes Marcie Catlin cried but horns and
drums in the clash of Steel smothered
her plea sir Ryman buried the head of
the ax in desi stomach by then men were
pouring in the other doors as well
mailed men in shaggy fur cloaks was
steel in their hands Northman she took
them for rescue for half a heartbeat
till one of them struck the small Jon's
head off with two huge blows of his axe
hope blew out like a candle in a storm
in the midst of slaughter the lord of
the crossing said on his carved oak
enthroned watching greedily there was a
dagger on the floor a few feet away
perhaps it had skittered there when the
small Jon knocked the table off its
trestles or perhaps that had fallen from
the hand of some dying man Catelyn
crawled toward it her limbs were Lenin
and the taste of blood was in her mouth
I will kill Walder Frey she told herself
jingle bell was closer to the knife
hiding under a table but he only cringed
away as she snatched up the blade I will
kill the old man I can do that much at
least
then the table top that small John had
flung over Rob's shifted and her son
struggled to his knees he had an arrow
in his side a second in his leg a third
through his chest
Lord Walder raised a hand in the music
stopped all but one drum Catelyn heard
the crash of distant battle and closer
the wind howling of a wolf gray when she
remembered too late hey Lord Walder
cackling at raw
the king in the North arises seems we
killed some of your men your grace
oh but I'll make you an apology that
will mend them all again
Catlin grabbed a handful of Jingle Bell
phrase long gray hair and dragged him
out of his hiding place
Lord Walder she shouted Lord Walder the
drumbeats slow in sonorous don't bomb
dome enough said Catelyn enough I say
you have repaid betrayal with betrayal
let it end when she pressed her dagger
to jingle bells' throat the memory of
bran sickroom came back to her with the
feel of Steel at her own throat the drum
went boom boom boom boom boom dome
please she said he is my son my first
son in my last let him go let him go and
I swear we will forget this forget all
you've done here I swear it by the old
gods in the new we we will take no
vengeance
Lord Walder peered at her and mistrust
only a fool would believe such blather
do you take me for a fool my lady I take
you for a father keep me for a hostage
admire as well if you haven't killed him
but let Robb go know Rob's voice was
whisper faint mother no yes Rob get up
get up and walk out please please save
yourself if not for me for Jane Jane Rob
grabbed the edge of the table and forced
himself to stand mother he said greywind
go to him now Rob walk out of here
Lord Walder snorted and why would I let
him do that
she pressed the blade deeper into jingle
bells' throat the lack weight rolled his
eyes at her and mute appeal a foul
stench assailed her nose but she paid it
no more mind than she did the sullen
ceaseless pounding of that drum boom
boom boom boom boom boom sir Ryman and
Blackwater were circling round her back
but Catelyn did not care they could do
as they wished with her
imprison her rape her kill her it made
no matter she had lived too long and Ned
was waiting it was robbed she feared for
on my honor as a Tully
she told Lord Walter on my honor as a
stark I will trade your a boy's life for
Rob's a son for a son her hand shook so
badly she was ringing jingle bells and
boom the drum sounded bomb dome bomb
dome the old man's lips went in and out
the knife trembled in Catlins hand
slippery was sweating a son for a son
huh he repeated but that's a grandson
and he never was much use a man in dark
armor and a pale pink cloak spotted with
blood stepped up the wrong Jaime
Lannister sends his regards he thrust
his long sword through her son's heart
and twisted Robb had broken his word but
Catelyn kept hurts she tugged hard on
Aegon's hair insult at his neck until
the blade grated on bone blood ran hot
over her fingers his little bells were
ringing ringing ringing in the drum went
boom boom boom finally someone took the
knife away from her the tears burned
like vinegar as they ran down her cheeks
ten fierce ravens were raking her face
was sharp talons and tearing off strips
of flesh leaving deep furrows that ran
red with blood she could taste it on her
lips it hurts so much
she thought or children Ned all our
sweet babes
Rickon brand Arya Sansa Rob Rob please
Ned please make it stop make it stop
hurting the white tears and the red ones
ran together until her face was torn and
tattered the face that Ned had loved
Catelyn Stark raised her hands and
watched the blood run down her long
fingers over her wrists beneath the
sleeves of her gown slow red worms
crawled along her arms and under her
clothes it tickles that made her laugh
until she screamed mad someone said
she's lost her wits and someone else
said make an end
in a hand grabbed her scalp just as
she'd done what jingle bell and she
thought no don't don't cut my hair Ned
loves my hair then the steel was at her
throat in its bite was red and cold
you
you